[Music]
530 million miles from the Sun
a tiny lump of ice and rock
starts its Journey towards the inner
solar system
scientifically comets are more precious
than pure gold
they are actual time capsules they are
preservations of what the chemistry the
environment was like when our solar
system formed and they hold Clues as to
how our chemistry arrived here on Earth
comets are some of the most valuable
scientific Treasures that exist
finding a comet we can study is not an
easy task
finding the right Comet for a mission
it's kind of like you're auditioning
them right one comes in and it's like oh
that Orbit's okay but it's not exactly
what we're looking for and oh this one's
too big this one's too little this one's
too active
what we really want to see is that comic
come from outer parts of the solar
system and get heated up as it gets
close to the sun pass around the Sun and
head back out to the outer part of the
solar system so if you need to get way
out in the solar system and catch a
comet on its way in
Comet 67p fits the bill
the special thing about comet 67p is how
accessible it is here on Earth it
actually orbits around the Sun once
every six and a half years and its orbit
doesn't take it all that far out only
about as far out as the planet Jupiter
that gives us many chances to actually
reach the comet and successfully
rendezvous with it
57p's moment in the spotlight arrived
the European Space Agency launched the
groundbreaking Rosetta probe
for years we've studied comets from afar
we had never seen one up close with
Cutting Edge technology to learn about
how comets behave as they orbit the Sun
missions to large planet-sized objects
are hard
the Hubble Space telescope's blurry
images revealed Rosetta's Target it's
just two miles wide
and not just a small Target a moving one
Comet 67p races through the solar system
at over 33 000 miles an hour
Precision involved is pretty incredible
it's like making that hole in one golf
shot from New York to San Francisco but
catching Comet 67p wasn't just a
straight shot
the spacecraft had to actually get the
same sort of velocity as the comet and
with current propulsion systems we can't
achieve that by flying directly to the
comet
instead Rosetta performed a slingshot
maneuver that would take 10 years
it's what it's doing it's actually
taking some energy away from the planet
so it's slowing the planets down a
little bit and then imparting that
energy into the probe
Rosetta flew past Jupiter nearly 100
million miles from the warmth of the Sun
and entered the most dangerous part of
its Journey
hibernation
Rosetta had solar panels on it it still
asleep
the reason for that is that it had to
track 67p a ways away from the Sun and
there just was not enough collection
area and solar power to be able to power
the instruments
there's no more to put spacecraft into
hibernation but the worrying thing at
the back of your mind is that it had
never been done for this long before
31 months of hibernation gave Rosetta's
team plenty of time to worry about what
could go wrong
it's dark and cold out there in space
there's a lot of things going on there's
a lot of little micro meteorites out
there and without the constant
communication with that spacecraft
just as a little nerve-wracking when the
day comes and it's time to flip the
switch and turn it back on
January 20th 2014.
after almost 10 years in space it was
finally time for Rosetta to wake up
reactivate its communication system
and phone home
I mean the tension was just palpable it
was just I mean how long do we have to
wait before we're going to get the
signal it's got to work it has to work
oh gosh maybe it's just not going to
turn on at all
have we lost the spacecraft
and then the peak appeared on the graph
it's like yes we've got contact with it
with a spacecraft
[Music]
Rosetta began to send back images of its
Target
and after months of seeing a small dot
in the distance
the comet slowly came into Focus
saw this
this mountain floating in space of ice
and rock
my heart just dropped they were some of
the most dramatic beautiful images I
have ever seen
and then as it got closer and we got to
see more and more details on it yeah
that's when things started getting
really strange
quite simply arrival at 67p
we expected to see something shaped like
a potato and we found something shaped
like a rubber duck
67p is no ugly duckling but its strange
shape created a problem for Rosetta
orbiting the comet was going to be far
more difficult than anyone had imagined
the planet has a lot of gravity so you
can send the spacecraft there and then
just down a little bit burn and it'll
drop into orbit
com at 67p you're dealing with a very
small Little Rock the spacecraft cannot
feel the gravity of that rock at least
not until it's right up against it
well the engineers had to actually plot
triangular orbits it was a very
complicated set of maneuvers
once in orbit Rosetta could start work
it's first task figure out how 67p
formed
how did this Comet get
that it was eroded somehow in the center
and so it started off as a more
spherical thing and became the shape it
is today through some unknown process
the other idea is that it started as two
separate objects
space rocks normally hit each other hard
they collide with an average impact
speed of more than 11 000 miles an hour
that's five times faster than a rifle
bullet
with 67p involved in a pile up
a clue came from the distinct layers on
the comet's surface
the layers in Comet 67p are a little
like the layers in an onion
if you see them aligned that's a clue
that perhaps the object formed as a
single entity and only eroded later into
its present form but if you see those
layers misaligned like we actually do in
the comet that's a big clue that it
started out as two separate objects
formed independently sticking together
to form the comet we see today
the layers prove that 67p was originally
two separate objects that fused together
the process of potentially putting Comet
67p together from two different pieces
is important because it can teach us
about what was happening in the early
solar system
so as far as we can tell these two
separate bodies must have been formed in
the same area they're very similar in
composition
but they are so light and fluffy that
they would have destroyed each other if
they had hit fast they had a low speed
collision and basically stuck together
like two wet snowballs
with one mystery solved Rosetta began to
investigate the chemical makeup of 67p
the little Comet could answer one of the
biggest questions in planetary science
from where did our Blue Planet get its
water